offers 1.1 billion dollars to have
kylian mbappe join their Saudi Arabian
club for just one season there is a 332
million dollar transfer fee that is
going to PSG so mbappe's salary will
start at 776 million dollars let's just
break that down he's making 64.6 million
dollars a month 14.7 million dollars a
week 2.1 million dollars a day really
think about that for one second he's
making over a million dollars a day he's
making 88 000 an hour and 24 a second he
could afford to ubereats me lunch in one
second Cristiano Ronaldo moved to the
Saudi pro league and said he won't be
returning to any European League he said
European football has lost its quality
and he wants others to join the Saudi
pro league and mbappe might be the next
big name to make the move